[Musique]
il remarque que les touristes qui
visitent le louvre ont l'habitude de
plus en plus de venir pique [ __ ] soit
dans les jardins qui sont dans la cour
intérieure soit sur les bancs qui sont
le long des galeries et même dans les
jardins du carrousel or dans ces dans
ces lieux on ne trouve pas de corbeil ce
qui fait que les détritus s'accumulent
et veulent avec le van houtte ce
viennent s'accumuler contre les galeries
et contre les monuments surtout en ce
moment avec les jeux de munich
beaucoup de touristes transitent par
paris est certainement ces gens là
doivent avoir une piètre opinion de des
français et des parisiens en particulier
à votre avis quelles seraient les
remèdes à apporter à cet état de choses
je pense que très simple de mettre des
corbeilles et bien les places et de
veiller à ce que des gens ils mettent
leurs déchets et surtout d'assurer un
service d'enlèvement pour ne pas les
papiers vols de tous les côtés et même
se livrent les fenêtres du ministre des
finances
ça dépend ça se répare excessive ans et
avec eux une douzaine de corbeil mis en
place et on enverrait la fin
monsieur le coeur à raison de s'indigner
devant le spectacle déplorable qui
s'offrent aux visiteurs de l'un des
trois monuments les plus fréquentés de
france
ces images d'immondices et de papiers
gras abandonnés à eux mêmes se passe de
commentaires
[Musique]
dans ces lieux le pique nique est bel et
bien autorisé ces touristes laisserait
volontiers leurs déchets dans des
corbeilles si elle existait et s'il
suffit de poser 50 corbeil au total pour
tous les jardins du louvre et du
carrousel solution modeste mais pourtant
efficace l'administration des beaux-arts
hésitera tél il en va soyons en
persuadés de la réputation de la
capitale
[Musique]